late december in beirut
the government had loosened coronavirus
restrictions at the end of a horrific
year
[Music]
for a few days across the city and
across the country
people relaxed
the consequence of that fateful decision
is a health system now
overwhelmed this is the casualty
department at rafiq hariri university
hospital
[Music]
[Music]
is 53 she first began to feel unwell 15
days ago
her family had hoped she'd recover at
home but this week
things got worse
38.
have been working literally around the
clock grabbing sleep when they can
for new year's eve or even during the
past year
we have seeing number of
not not more than 100 cases per day
now we are seeing 5 000 6 000 patients
positive cases per day much younger
people
across the city this is the red cross
call center
here
from here teams
[Music]
positive first over and she is currently
suffering from the saturation
and vomiting so we're gonna go ahead
assess her and try to take care of that
and see if there's need to go to
the hospital
[Music]
their patient is madame imad 80 years
old she tested positive last week
her diabetes is complicating things she
needs to go to hospital but there's a
problem
currently we're having an issue with the
hospital so they're trying to find a vet
for us to be able
to move
the positivity rate across the city is
22
at the moment that means community
spread of the virus
is out of control
but she was sent home again there were
no beds
they're filled with a growing number of
people young and elderly
who need them more mark stone sky news